皆さんこんにちははじめ社長です皆
売れちょっと皆さんに僕の悩み事を話そうと思いますあの僕動画ですごい
ペラペラしゃべってるように見えるじゃないですかたぶん今も動画だとすごい速度だけ
だけど食べてるんだと思うんですけども実際そうじゃないですよあの北
本当にしゃべれなくて自分でもちょっとじまど神返してたんですよ僕の茶ベリーが全く
出来ないという事を皆様にもうしようと思ってちょっと自分の動画を見返してて事情だ
なと思いましてなんて言うんだろうねかまかんでもいるんですよためんですけどもう気
に食わなかったら後1回同じ事を言っちゃう
うまく説明できないな最近もんでところカバー日本語
適当にされちゃう
それもまたわからないんですけどとりあえず多分見てもらったら分かると思うんです
けども僕同じことを何回も繰り返してしゃべる癖がついてしまっていますいっぱい
ちょっと見てみてください
vtr どうぞ私は今回ここに私が今回空に私は今回コンビニュってうん
自分のですよまあこれはが彼女じゃわかりませんだ加工
嫌だったんでしょうね自分のこと子どもな感じが家で私今ここにデブと散々言って3代
目で気に入って言ったっていう例ですまあ3000もおかしいですけどまあまあ予想し
ましょう次2エアホッケー点普通はエアホッケーってどんなのか
2エアホッケーってこのう
普通やバンケットほど床から空気が出ている
1回増えたね杖ホッケー普通 ao 聞いてじゃあ今もうにか言った者の道なんか
おかしくなってる女だねぇ
間違えても何とかなると思ってんだろうね編集でユーチューバー秒子みたいになって
ますね
2へホッケーっという簡単な言葉を4回も連続で売ってるんですよ病気あんアレです
アレです
こちらでです
こちらですこちらです線香花火でござる
うん
me
あれで5回分だよ誰もいないところでもう随分で見ててをかなりヤバいと思ってます
杉生ですどうぞ
海底でコレなにかと言いますとブライトクロックということでございますあコレなにか
というかフレイでをしたフロックというものです
なんか考えてる気に食わなかったんでしょうねえっ
ええええこれで何かと言いますと
これ何がと言います我々はそれじゃねーよこれ誰かと言いますとマン
まぁコレなにかといってこれ何かと言いますと最近ちょっと話題になっ
これ何かといいますと
俺のターンああ俺のターンが俺だと俺のターン
みたいなもうなんか松屋いてもいいと思ってるから一番的にも言葉がうまく出てこない
んですよ次
チーズチっ子チーズ等のペンぐちー時キー
こんな今回このバンド開け鍋が入ってあげていか方って言うんでしょうかあの特に
どうするってわけでもないんですけど10人に困っておりますどうだの言い直しが多
すぎるからのところカバ塚部氏でも失敗してもいい言葉が言っちゃうから失敗を恐れ
ない精神になってるんですよねそう言ったらいいコトっぽいなんてよく
ないですよ実際リアルな世界だと本当に役に立たないリアルな世界だと本当にももうに
か言ったもう今なら変なところで完璧主義者なんでしょうね絶対これがいいっていう
感じで言うまで食べ取り直さないと気がすまないねようになってるんで多分動画の裏側
だとこんな風にめちゃくちゃなことになっているんです実はと言うなやに事
編集で何度かそれから見る
さんには問題ないんですけどこれを繰り返しする生徒日常でも結構一羽と民主が多く
なっているのでますます僕のコミュ障が
加速するぜさぁみんな月曜日頑張っていきましょうばいばーい
何の動画だよ
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
あっはぁ